[Music]
hey it's our 50th matinee show
yeah and Jenny's boobs are crooked we
had a straightener ma well you know that
our this shirt was I was just looking in
the camera and I'm like straight that's
like wait
we got three movies we got a review yeah
we actually did not go to the theater
this week because just because like
nothing new really started and Dean why
would I honor movies bad movies are on
there right now
it's ok good ones you come ones like
some of them might be good but it wasn't
really anything we were the new really
interested in seeing rambo is gonna be
coming Joker is gonna be coming I want
to see that knives out movie that murder
mystery with Daniel Cragen that's Rian
Johnson in it yeah yeah it's gonna be
bad I don't know I think it looks cool I
like murder mysteries alright but you
know so there's there's ones coming out
that we want to see but there weren't
any this week so this week yeah wait to
interpret Terminator dark flop that's
coming out like I said I see
I don't like watch all this stupid [ __ ]
where people are just like whining about
stuff before it comes it's like I'll see
it and then I'll make it is it's really
only been one good Terminator movie and
one of them that was except passable yes
yeah and then part two is acceptable the
first one was good yeah two is
acceptable it's funny because like a lot
of people really liked the second one
but when I rewatched I was like oh that
wasn't as good as ever
it's an it's only just because of that
kid is super good and it's like so so so
90s I guess I could not even deal with
it yeah and the other ones I don't
really can who cares I don't even think
I bothered watching so I wouldn't even
know what was going on in the new one or
whatever
soon as the damn sky name starts talking
I checked out oh that's right yeah cuz
maybe I dis guy that should have never
said anything that should it be like an
insect computer type intelligence that
doesn't have a face and unknowable
as soon as you start putting a face and
a voice to it well yeah personal life
see that's what happens and like you
know if people are making horror movie
you know out there take note your
villain is always scarier when you don't
know that much it about them the more
you explain their backstory the more you
explain their motivations and stuff like
that
the less scary they get yeah we're gonna
review three movies these were all on
Netflix and the hall from 2019 one was
okay I didn't see much of it the other
two it in life okay yeah yeah this that
the one we're talking about that's the
one that was probably my favorite of the
week yeah the one that I liked I
actually had to start cooking and guess
I missed oh yeah so he was like running
although I liked that one it was funny
yeah I did all right so the first one
we're going to talk about came out May
17th 2009 teen on Netflix it was called
see you yesterday yeah
now this was the directorial writing and
directorial debut of a guy named Stefan
Bristol Spike Lee also produced this one
this is kind of like okay the the
beginning of it it's the set up of it is
kind of like you think it's gonna be
like back to the future like I mean like
it's gonna be an even Michael J Fox has
a toucan cameo in it like science
teacher which which that was the best
part of movie and this that also [ __ ]
this movie up because it set the bar
high well and also what I did like this
movie but I think that maybe it
shouldn't have set that tone at the
beginning because like the first 15 20
minutes yeah you think it's gonna be
like a goofy like time-travel come to
sit as a sci-fi movie marginally but
after the time-travel starts to happen
[ __ ] gets dark real fast yeah so this
movie ends up like I said it's a good
movie but it ends up being like kind of
a bummer it's like really really sad and
grim so I think that mates tonally it
was a little weird because I wasn't
really sure what was what was you know
like I said if I I think if I hadn't
known ahead of time
I just news like oh it's about a kid
that invents a time machine and you know
hijinks ensue or whatever so that's
pretty much all I knew about it um but
it's not the the funny thing that you
would think that Michael J Fox being in
there and all the shenanigans at the
beginning was lazy - III think the
Rotten Tomatoes score [ __ ] tells it
all critic the critic training was in
99% good you know talking about this is
99% but you know the viewer rating is
like 25 like I said yeah if you know
what you're getting into you probably
like it better but because I wasn't sure
like where it was going too many
mistakes were made in the movie like I
said and it was all it was tonal
problems also just when you have goofy
when you have a goofy print premise and
goofy looking characters and goofy
time-travel [ __ ] the movie has to be
fast-paced and fun that's not what this
movie was this movie this hogan was a
[ __ ] bummer and and and here's the
deal it's not a long movies pretty it's
not I think it's like 85 minutes
something yeah it seemed to just take it
does seem of area and the characters are
so tedious and wordy and there's just so
much useless talking and it's just it's
you end up just going like shut the [ __ ]
up I would say that got sick of the
movie fast I will say that I liked the
kids at the center of it um the girl
that plays CJ who's like the main
character and she has a friend named
Sebastian and basically they're both
kind of like they're at like the that
science high school the special science
high school and musics I think that are
in Brooklyn Carrodus the characters were
good ideas just that they didn't do
anything with them and the story didn't
do the game yeah that's basically what
she does is they've invented like for
this project that's coming up they've
invented essentially a time machine that
makes a wormhole and it fits in a
backpack um Ghostbuster style yeah the
problem that is that you can only go
back one day now they really don't think
about the implications of this because
they just think oh we're just going back
one day we'll try not to change anything
it won't be this big deal or anything
like that but they go back one day one
little change gets made and tragedy
occurs so then the rest of the story is
her trying to you know fix the problem
like
and you know change another little thing
like so hopefully the tragedy doesn't
happen but that other tragedy happens
and so it's just kind of like the rest
of the movie it's just her kind of like
trying to go back and like fix her
mistake because it actually kind of was
her fault that she went time-traveling
and that you know the [ __ ] happened
because I don't think it would have
happened anyway would it that's what
that's what spurred off what in series
of events what ends up happening is that
the movie quickly starts falling apart
for tonal reasons and it ends up getting
I was about 20-30 minutes in it and I
stopped caring about what was happening
to the kingdom if the fatal fall or the
way of this movie is that I think
bringing Michael J Fox in and making
back to the future references sets the
movie up for failure okay
I would agree with that yeah I think the
thing is gonna be conovan like a wacky
right what does I travel one of the
major all those Back to the Future
movies great is that they're very tight
stories very fast-paced very superficial
but they had impact yeah it didn't
wallow in anything you know what I mean
even a serious subject in Back to the
Future was kind of treated flippantly
yeah all right because it doesn't get
bogged down in the weight of its own
emotions as it continues to move forward
and it's basically an optimistic tale ya
know they're gonna work it out this is
exactly the opposite I would call this
like I said I actually did kind of like
this already but I would I would have
not um set it up in the beginning as
being like almost a comedic type of tone
or a fun type of tone yeah because this
movie is like really it's a tragedy
essentially yeah and it's really kind of
nihilistic yeah although the ending of
it I'm not gonna spoil it or anything
but um the ending of it does leave it
open or like ambiguous about like what
happens past a certain point so you
could read it that you could read in an
optimistic way but a lot of the [ __ ]
that happens in the movie is very
Annihilus yeah and I think the reason
why it's done that is because they're
trying to make they're trying to make
relevant political statements to today
but it ends up just being demoralizing
to the audience so you know
it's like cuz because they're hopeless
whoever's watching
whoever's right in this [ __ ] because
they have no hope they're trying to make
everybody else have no hope
so it's defeating the audience if yes
this is not what an audience wants to
see you look at the damn cover of the of
the movie and it looks like it's the
poster look think it's gonna be a real
fun ya got kids movie no not at all it's
a bummer it's a total bummer it doesn't
even have a very good sense of humor
it's just like all the funny stuff
happens like in the first 15 20 yeah and
after that it's just the whole thing
just kind of falls apart and it just
after that it's just everyone is lazy
sin misery yeah it's it's it's got a
political agenda it's trying to sell you
which immediately will turn you off you
know I mean he asked me I was gonna say
it's like I I have run into this a lot
on Netflix I'm not sure who designs
their little cards maybe they maybe they
don't have a person that designed some
Maties whoever made the movie like you
know whoever is the graphic designer
yeah might have been a hodgepodge of
different people try yeah I feel like
and it wasn't just this movie but I've
seen like a lot of movies were like the
little cards on that come up on Netflix
really kind of misrepresented with the
movie about you sometimes you'll like
see the card and and it works sometimes
in the opposite direction too like
sometimes I see a card in there I'm like
that looks like it's gonna be the
stupidest thing ever but like them when
I watch them like good like maybe
somebody else should have designed the
card because they didn't really or maybe
whoever capture the spirit of the movie
yeah whoever whatever did the card
should be what should have watched the
movie maybe they don't maybe they don't
have time to yeah well it must must be a
movie like this because I mean I'm
designed I've done like artwork for
various things not necessarily movies
except for a couple indie ones but what
usually ends up happening is that your
band or your movie production company or
whatever they usually have like a set
number of stills or a set number of like
you know photographs like from the movie
and they'll basically just send you
those this is the font we're gonna use
this is the logo of the movie or
whatever and you just put it together
like that so sometimes the designer has
not seen the movie I would imagine
because sometimes I've seen those that
artwork that just there's nothing like
what the movie is like
yeah yeah like I said I I liked it but
keep in mind that you know the way that
it's represented and like in the artwork
and the way that you think it's gonna go
in the first 10 to 15 minutes like get
it severe it's sad it's tragic it's not
any it's no fight it's not a fun movie
yeah another thing is is that what its
setting it up like it's gonna have kind
of like a Back to the Future movie
thematic feel to it but that's not the
tone or the feel as a a few minutes into
it from about 15-20 minutes into it it
has the feel of a Netflix series yeah it
feels like a Netflix series it does
actually input into just 88 minutes that
yeah that the tone is wrong I think part
of it is that there's no score oh I
didn't notice that yeah I think now that
I'm not thinking about any kind of score
and bringing in Michael J Fox to help
set the tone and a damn time travel
movie this sitting on work without a
[ __ ] epic score because Back to the
Future was music driven yeah everything
happened there's that big you know what
he called orchestral board big
orchestral score to the background you
know it sounded very epic this sounded
you didn't really have a sound it's just
like a it's like a it's like an epic
series I'm gonna actually a lot of
Netflix series actually have good scores
yeah but this one down I'm going to say
that actually like even though the genre
of this is listed as sci-fi I'm gonna
say it's basically a drama but it uses
because there's not a huge amount of
time travel yes time travel is like you
know kind of the fulcrum and that the
plot turns on but there isn't a lot of
like time-travel stuff in it yeah
basically just talking they're standing
in an alley like when they go and they
just have backpacks so it's not like the
you know it shows them like working on
the time machine and stuff like that but
it's basically just trying to go back
and like fix these horrible things that
have gone wrong and tragedies that have
occurred yeah too much talking not
enough action most of it should have
been a bunch of running a bunch of gags
jumping over stuff starts you know
because if you know you look at back to
the future you know which that's that's
the tone we're trying to set in the
beginning back to the future was kind of
hammy yeah I mean a lot of stuff
happened in it it's you know it's a
there's a lot of blocking yeah that you
know it's almost like is almost like a
like a stage act yeah it's not like a
musical you know so some of the some of
the stuff that you see happen in Back to
the Future and this compared to that
just feels kind of dead yeah I think I
would have liked it better if they
hadn't tried to do that if they hadn't
tried to like establish it as a Back to
the Future type of move if they had
established the tone right from the
outset yeah I think I would have liked
it it would have been a lot more better
because you you would become invested in
the story be sure like okay this is how
the story is and that's how it's going
instead of expecting one thing and then
having it go right ahead it's kind of a
serious dark Tom to from the very
beginning yeah and then it would have
made a little more sense I think yeah
but no I just didn't like the movie yeah
and it's it's kind of a shame because it
could have been good it's a good concept
yeah it could have been good it was
there I think maybe you could have saved
it and edit and adding a proper score
yeah and it different advertising
packaging around it yeah and I mean like
the poster the movie poster but a little
bit different maybe you could have sold
it in a different way yeah but trying to
establish it as a fun kid based time
travel movie like Back to the Future
no you just shot yourself in the foot
with that one yeah yeah I agree yeah
you
and the second movie watched on Netflix
this week was murder mystery which came
out June 14th actually when it first
came out I think this was the highest
watched movie of all the Netflix
originals you know yeah up until this
point I [ __ ] this one up you did yeah
I [ __ ] it up cuz I had to do I had
chores and [ __ ] I had to do what you
didn't have to do it but you whether
yeah you know there's only so many
there's only so many hours in a day
there's stuff I had to do this actually
was a good one
yeah and every time I fought back in to
see what's going on yeah it's kind of
like I'd like to see it again yeah it is
a chick flick if you asked me is it's
not being market this is not being
marketed to guys even though I think
Adam Sandler is actually kind of like a
woman's comedian I think I think women
like him better I don't like that I'm
saying you got that of it every time I
see I'm Sandler movies it always seems
carve like a like a woman like a michael
movie saw the aim to women if you ask me
are you kidding me we're really like
happy gilmore like all this but the
water boy those are total dude movies
really yeah oh man I wouldn't watch that
neither would I though okay well then
it's not the kind of man that I am
they're just do it I don't know because
because they're like dumb like slapstick
okay like just peeing on [ __ ] and it's
all there kind of I don't know it's not
my kind of humor so you know I don't
really know who they're for but the
thing about this one is and like I said
I'm not a gigantic fan of Adam Sandler I
haven't seen like a lot of his comedies
um you know if I did I don't to me it
all meant to me it seems effeminate I
don't I don't I don't get that but like
I said I never liked that I'm saying
maybe just maybe I always thought he was
like kind of stupid yes I thought that
was like a guy thing
okay no I thought he was just trying to
be cute for for women or something no no
I never I never really know there's some
kind of a man out there that watches
this well yeah like I said a lot of his
early comedies are like kind of dude
comedy classic compared to me they
probably wore man anyway yeah could just
be other women compared to me but the
thing about this one like I said I
needed air chain that [ __ ]
and it's like a does he go and like I
don't really have any idea you're
talking about because Adam Sandler
movies are like super popular like his
old ones at least are they now I guess
like Adam Sandler like I said I haven't
seen like a lot of his movies but he is
apparently like has a contract with
Netflix to produce like X amount of
films or whatever so this is the ones
that he did before this which I haven't
seen so I can't like really comment but
the ones that he did before this
apparently didn't get roll of good
reviews or anything now this one has
done substantially better now this is
basically it's a comedy obviously and
it's like a whodunit like you know
murder mystery which is why it's called
that it's got that girl from friends in
it yeah Jennifer Aniston is in it yeah I
called her a girl she's a woman now well
yeah she's probably my age or older
she's older now I guess that Adam
Sandler and Jennifer Aniston had been
together in a comedy like back in 2011 I
can't remember the name of it and
apparently like people thought like they
had really good like comedic chemistry
together so I thought I thought Adam
Sandler was on friends actually yeah he
was like oh and they were both on
friends I'm like what are you talking
about Adam Sandler wasn't on friend look
it just goes to show you I didn't even
watch friends and I thought this goes to
show you I'm not a mainstream guy I
don't watch television I don't know what
I never watched it either I mean I don't
know what not with quote unquote normal
people like I don't know what they like
I don't either you know but I do know
that Adam Sandler wasn't on friends I
know that first they all look alike to
me okay they all look alike but yeah so
this is basically so basically the setup
of it it's not like a super original
setup or anything like that it's
basically Adam Sandler is a police
sergeant who has actually been lying to
his wife and said that he got promoted
to Detective and got a raise and
everything he has failed the test like
three times cuz he's like a running gag
throughout the film is like he's a
really rotten shot but he's been telling
her that he's a detective and he has
more money and [ __ ] like that she's a
hairdresser I think and so it's coming
up on their 15th wedding anniversary and
he like does the sad husband thing and
like Biser this stupid looking card and
like a $50 Amazon gift card like that
for their 15th anniversary and then she
finally was like you know when we got
married you said that we would go to
Europe so even though he's still broke
dick because he hasn't got the promotion
yet he's like okay well I booked a trip
to Europe he lied and he said that he
booked it a long time ago but he just
like booked it real quick because she
complained so while they're on the plane
going to Europe um
Jennifer Aniston's character whose name
is Audrey meets this real suave like
super rich dude when she goes to sneak
up to first class this guy says oh hey
why don't you come and you know hang out
on my family's yacht for a little while
we're going to Monaco and also the kind
of crap yeah for no real reason not yeah
not really I thought they were gonna
like I thought they were gonna do more
with that yeah but I guess it was just
kind of like a plot devices like I said
just to get them there because it was no
other way so they end up like on this
rich dudes yacht and it turns out that
the purpose for the whole yacht
excursion which is like this family and
it's like it's some of them are family
members and firmer like various
hangers-on of like this billionaire
family the billionaire who is played by
Terence Stamp who really needs to be in
this movie more because I love Terence
Stamp and he was like really really good
in this so he basically announces that
he has married his 23 year old wife rich
didn't matter and that all of you all of
you family members and your hangers-on
you're all leeches are all cut off y'all
cut off you're not getting anything
you're not getting any of my money yeah
so the lights go out and he gets stabbed
yeah so then the rest of it is just kind
of like this you know mr. a pretty much
murder mystery it's very much like clue
not as Amy is that very standard it's
very very standardized it's not trying
the movie is not trying to do anything
new it's actually plan on old tropes
yeah some people say well that's very
lazy yeah but sometimes that's what
works not as I don't think it was it's
like like I don't you don't think it
worked no yeah that's that's what I was
gonna say I was like I know I was gonna
say I don't think it's lazy necessarily
some people would say that
um because it was a and B was not
totally originated can be it was not a
totally original idea or a totally
original movie but that's what made it
work yeah cuz it was a it's an it was a
known genre and it is stuck to the
tropes of that genre yeah I feel like if
you're going to do like I said yes it's
lazy if you're just using that as a
crutch to lean on and you're not gonna
like trying to do anything interesting
with the characters or anything but I
think that if you're going to do that
and use like a very standard you know
plot like this then you know your
character interactions all of you know
the mystery how it unfurls and stuff
like that have to be like really good
and really enjoyable it's a vehicle for
a bunch of jokes and gags yeah that
worked really well yeah in this movie um
Adam Sandler's character like I said I'm
not a huge fan of his but he was fine in
this you know he was very grumbling and
kind of slubby and stupid and like he
didn't like you know so Jennifer Aniston
was kind of like the brains of the
operation and the two of them do work
very well together like they it you
could actually buy that they'd been
married for 15 years because they were
just got like constantly squabbling and
like this is talking [ __ ] about each
other I still think this was a chick
flick I don't care what you say to me I
think that I think it was targeted
towards women maybe but I said I don't
yeah there's a lot of relationship humor
in it stuff it was no no that's true I
saw I saw I saw that one Adam Sandler
movie you're talking about water boy
yeah I thought I did think it was funny
yeah I did think it was funny it was it
was very different from this one well
yeah like I said this isn't this is a
comedy but it's yeah like I said it was
a long time ago that I saw that a I'm
Sandler movie but I think you're right
it it was there was targeted more to
guys well yeah all of his early movies
yeah it was that's why I did I'm just
well yeah I'm [ __ ] around a little bit
you know when I do the show yes yeah it
was marketed more to guys but kind of
like dumb guys yeah yeah that's I mean
that's why I didn't really get like a
lot of that I don't know I did I do kind
of like steep stupid humor sometimes
like like Adam Sandler's character in
this like said some stupid [ __ ] and he
was kind of like useless
and everything but he did like have some
really funny lines and this although
Jennifer Aniston I think had the best
lines and uh and the the ensemble cast
like all of the family members all the
suspects like in the murder they did a
good job making each of them like really
entertaining like in their own right you
know what I mean Luke Evans is in this
two dumbest I'll go with these comedies
is jagbag nacho libre I love that one
well I liked that movie break and yeah
yeah tenacious d that [ __ ] was hilarious
the thing about Adam Sandler that I
think bothers me rock is that because I
you know I can get behind dumb humor and
[ __ ] like that too but the thing about
Adam Sandler that bothered me it seems
like even when he's doing like goofy
humor there always seems to be like
anger or condescension behind it yeah
you know what I mean and maybe that's
just me that says that you're saying an
absence or secret Lisa [ __ ] yeah or so
he just always comes across as like a
little bit mean like even when he's not
yeah B even when the character doesn't
call for that right now he comes across
like that in this movie too but because
that's part of his character because
he's like been thrust into this
situation and he's a cop so he's trying
to figure out the thing and like
Jennifer Aniston's character is a
hairdresser like I said but she's like a
big fan of like murder mystery novels so
the two of them kind of have to like
team up to like solve the crime because
they actually because they're the only
like strangers and that ended up on this
yacht they actually get accused like by
the French police they get accused of
murdering the guy yeah and it actually
turns out B it turns out to be more than
one guy like more people died like
through the course of the thing so so
it's kind of like um you know I guess
it's kind of like a thing where they
they learn to like appreciate each
other's strengths again because you know
she's been getting all over his case for
being this lovely loser and who lied to
her and stuff and you know I'm not and
stuff like that so I mean like I said
it's it's not like it's a hugely over so
there's no twist or anything that's true
um I didn't really I didn't figure the
mystery out but I wasn't really trying
to I was just kind of like doesn't
matter it doesn't really matter like I
just kind of like enjoyed all the
characters and
like the airplane it's just it's just a
vehicle to tell a bunch of bunch of gags
and and say a bunch of jokes really it's
not really an important story yeah
pretty funny it's just a fun I mean I
laughed out loud a few times it's not
the funniest movie I've ever seen but um
yeah but yeah I did get like a lot of
laughs about its you know it's super fun
you just like sit back with a drink and
watch it and it's hilarious you know
what I mean and like I said this is
coming from somebody that's not a big
fan but they actually the the
interaction the two of them was good and
all the ensemble cast was really good
too that was like some funny like
character moments and [ __ ] like that in
there it was a couple things that I
might have changed I wish they would
have stayed on the yacht longer so it
was more like a clue of like a locker
room mystery rather than you know
getting released out into the wild and
running around the streets of Milan or
wherever it was I think it was I think
it was opposed to Monaco but I think it
was filmed it was okay if I didn't have
to review it and she wasn't with me I
would have turned it probably but okay
but like I said you didn't see a lot of
it because you're out there making tuna
salad or whatever I was but you know
ours I'm not really into that kind of or
per se it's just okay it's acceptable
yes you can see its humor for the whole
family
yeah so you know and like I said a lot
of these movies from my mom and you kind
of watered down I probably would have
got around to watching this eventually
anyway just cuz I like murder mysteries
and you know things around that you know
based around that premise I like things
but more ridiculous you know I mean like
Jack Black Oh take me take me yeah cuz
he's just ludicrous well like I said
this is like clue but not as rainy cuz
clue was like very funny like very very
over-the-top right this one didn't have
as much of that some of the characters
were a little bit over the top but not
as much as that one so it's not quite as
funny as that but it was perfectly
enjoyable and like I said you know I
probably would have got around to
watching this eventually anyway but you
know we're basically we're doing the
matinee shows they have to be new movies
so there's not a huge amount of 2019
movies on Netflix so you know it's not
like we have like a huge amount to pick
from so we just kind of pick the ones
that sounded like the most interesting
or that we might enjoy so you know
that's what I mean
but yeah so check it out if you haven't
seen it
in the third movie we watched this week
also on Netflix it actually came out
very early this year in 2019 this is the
science fiction film I oh yeah is it is
it just I or is it something that was an
operation IO or something that's the
thing it's like well the card for it
this is why I was confused cuz I was
looking for it on Netflix like on the
search thing and I think the card says
destination is yeah but if you look it
up on Wikipedia IMDB or anything it's
just called I oh yeah it was an
interesting movie it I would say this is
a well made movie yeah and I think it's
well thought out it wasn't a very fun
movie to watch it from my point of view
it it's long it's long and it's very
slow and it's missing a lot of elements
from from the story that I would like to
see you know I mean I would have trimmed
it way down made shorter and I do added
monsters yeah had added monsters and you
know some fighting so man you go ahead
and explain that the movies about it's
like the last woman on earth so there's
like an Omega man vibe yeah and see how
to taking it down that direction to
where yeah everybody's evacuated the
earth but they did they evacuated earth
for a certain reason and there have been
like some bad [ __ ] there that you had to
avoid so you could actually have some
action scenes or you know that means see
something scary but that's not there
it's just basically it's just slow this
is more yeah this is more like a
philosophical horror movie um sci-fi
movies very high-minded what it reminded
me the most of was the Martian except
set on earth because basically the
premise of the movie Margaret quality is
in this she's kind of like the main
character and she's played by yeah
Margaret quale she was in Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood yeah she played the
massive family girl with the hairy
armpits yeah the well they probably all
that but yeah the one that one fun it
was trying to blow the stunt man in the
car yeah yeah so she's in it and Anthony
Mackie
who was in a lot of the Marvel movies
among many many many others finding a
job in that movie she did yeah yeah
she's yeah the acting and this is very
good but like I said it's it's kind of
like the Martian but not okay so the
premise of the movie is that it's at
some point in the future I don't think
they ever tell you like how far in the
future it is what year it is or anything
but basically the earth has been
evacuated because they don't really
explain why but there was like some kind
of change in the chemical makeup of the
atmosphere and humans couldn't breathe
it anymore
so they started you know basically
evacuating the earth and they all go to
live on a space station right near
Jupiter's moon of Io animals couldn't
breathe it either and it killed all the
all the life in the ocean yeah like so
yes so basically the whole earth is
almost like a dead planet except like
certain high altitudes you can breathe
up there yeah that's the only place like
I guess like the oxygen is slowly
depleting or like you know being sucked
off into the atmosphere and then like
you know so there's little pockets where
people can still live but on the whole
you know most people have gone I don't
think the atmosphere is leaving I think
the atmosphere is like going toxic yeah
yeah
because seem like atmospheric pressure
was normal and there were some plants
growing yeah but I think they were dead
everywhere else yeah it was the movie
looked realistic and it seemed to you
know they did a really good job of kind
of showing an entire world or an
ecosystem you know because they would go
out and forage and find technology and
but she'd bring it back and make it into
stuff and her dad well that's a long
story she her dad was trying to come up
with a new a new genetics training annex
train to modify human beings so they
could live in this new atmosphere and
animals but it wasn't quite working out
evidently and it's weird she's on this
last outpost and she's talking to
somebody on the mom on the Isle call and
she got a boyfriend and she's been
transmitting her dad's messages out from
a radio station and some of his
teachings about you know well he was a
scientist you know about mutating people
I guess
genetically engineering people who live
in this yeah they started with animals
like they're trying to do they're trying
to do bees so they could get in pigs and
yeah all kinds of stuff and she was out
there one day and a balloon comes
there's a man in a balloon and he's
looking for her dad he was another guy
he was he he was convinced to stay there
by her father yeah but he lost his whole
family it the movie unfolds very slowly
it does have and you have to be very
patient with this movie so and I would
call this a true science fiction movie a
lot of things I was thinking that too
because it's very very realistic yeah
you know and a lot a lot of science
fiction movies are not really science
Dixmude more like action movies yeah you
know because that's what sells this
movie it's just not really for a general
audience it's kind of like I said is its
atmospheric it's kind of it's it's
intelligent it's an intelligent movie
yeah there's a lot of literary
references there's a lot of like
mythological references you know about
the Garden of Eden there so you know
some TS Eliot's stuff in there there's
okay we know what the painting Leda and
the Swan so you know it is kind of more
like an intellectual type of it's a good
movie it's a good movie it's very
intelligent it's not very fun to watch
no butter me I didn't I didn't really I
kind of feel very conflicted about it
because I understand what they're trying
to do it I'm trying to try to talk about
the movie without spoiling it because it
is a good quality movie yeah it's I
didn't really enjoy watching it yeah you
know I mean I would have taken the movie
down in another direction more kind of
like the Omega Man yeah I see we're
saying you know we're yeah it was
destroying all life in the earth but it
was mutating people too in media and the
animals into something that was hostile
I thought maybe something like that
would have been cool you know that way
you could have some more
action-adventure scenes yeah and then
they don't that doesn't really happen in
this way yeah like I said this is a very
like you said it's more like a true
sci-fi movie in the sense that this is
what it would be like if this is the
last woman on earth she has presumably
been born because I think her dad was
working on the
stuff before she was even born right so
she has actually been born on the earth
with this kind of toxic atmosphere and
so she so there's kind of like a
conflict the the whole conflict of the
movie is that you know when this other
person arrives like in the hot air
balloon his name is Micah yeah and he's
decided that he wants to leave because
basically most people on earth have left
that you know so you think that these
two people are pretty much the only ones
left alive but they're they're still
doing um
escape shuttles to go to IO now her
boyfriend has been trying to convince
her to let come to IO you know you know
you're not gonna like save the earth
it's like it's too late now we messed it
up or it's you know it's unlivable now
so you should take the last shuttle so
there's only one more shuttle and it's
coming in like four days or something
like that so she has to decide you know
when Micah comes should they leave on
the last shuttle because if she doesn't
go on the last shuttle then she's just
gonna be stuck on the planet right yeah
there's a bunch of ambiguity and with
this girl too
I don't I don't want to spoiling it it's
just that her whole thing was like
genetically modifying animals to adapt
to this new environment and it makes you
wondered if somewhere in a long alliance
she got genetically modified I think
that's what or because she was born on
the planet that she had that capability
maybe yeah they left it very ambiguous
and it you don't really find anything
out until the very end
yeah I would have done it differently
yeah I would have brought that out early
and then gone the direction of maybe
like the brood where she's given birth
to mutant human beings yeah yeah you
know you can't live on the place that
could live on the planet you know but
they were hostile to humans yeah I'd
have gone that way see because you
already had these good actors you
already had all these special effects
you had all this stuff let's do
something exciting with it that's how I
yeah you know kind of like the one that
one robot the one that we saw mother
mother yes I'd have done something kind
of like that yes more tension
yeah there was much tension this didn't
have some because it did
some mystery you weren't really sure
like what her endgame was you weren't
sure where Micah had come from like what
his endgame was yeah you weren't sure
how it was gonna turn out so there was
like some mystery like you know when
they interacted with one another and
whether they were telling each other the
truth it's just not quite enough for a
movie of this scope if you ask me yeah
if you're gonna go ahead and go through
the trouble of making this movie and
make it look that cool do some [ __ ] yeah
have some [ __ ] blow up you know have
some people get shot have some [ __ ]
monsters all right
stop being so intelligent the audiences
are not intelligent the average probably
average IQ is about 90 just show them
some [ __ ] catch you on fire and then you
know you know yeah but don't be
ambiguous but not everybody wants to
make a movie like that and not everybody
wants to watch movies I believe that
movies should be made to make money and
to and right but and to entertain people
like I said well other people are people
are entertained by different things yeah
I would think very few people would be
entertained by this I actually liked
this movie I will say about like I'd
like to see the Rotten Tomatoes score
the pacing on it was slightly baggy
there could have been a little bit that
could have been trimmed um that I
probably would have turned out but in
general um I thought it was pretty cool
like I was really invested in like the
two characters and like what was gonna
happen and like you know and I liked
like the the question behind it I liked
the concept behind it I saw I saw what
they were doing you know I did
appreciate what they did but the slow as
I'm gonna go I won't go any slower than
Blade Runner 28:48 2049 20:49 yeah
that's it I won't go any slower than
that I just slower than that I managed
it and I thought Blade Runner was
fantastic yeah it was but it was doing
bigger issues yeah you know what was
gonna inherit the universe human beings
replicants or androids yeah you know I'm
imagining you know Wallace Corporation
Tyrell corporation and you know there
was a lot of stuff happening in that
even though that tom was kind of even
though a pacer yeah it was kind of the
slow pace was kind of an illusion in a
way there was a lot happening yeah it
was slow but it was also big yeah you
know
the city's capers which like I said this
was this was going for that I think
because it did have some big themes
behind it and speaking I mean she's the
last person on earth they're saying
about genetic engineering and yeah you
know whether people should come back
from IO like when will will the earth be
habitable by humans again and things
like that it just won't show on us very
mind off yeah that's true like I said a
lot of it was conveyed through universe
ation or through other things and there
wasn't enough conflict yeah like you
know I mean there should have been some
kind of monsters there yeah that they
were escaping from yeah animals yeah
dangerous animals yeah okay I get we
just I mean I like this but like I said
it's it's a pretty slow movie it's very
similar in tone to the Martian I thought
it was very simple Ike funny moments in
it too but it's as if it's a similar
kind of vibe yeah you know so if you're
into kind of more slow-paced more
serious like you know quote-unquote
high-minded sci-fi or something like
that like a very like a science fiction
movie and and realism isn't the greatest
thing to watch on but keep in mind that
I mean if you're not invested in these
two characters then you might as well
just start it off because those two
carrots are pretty much the only two
people in the whole movie and their
interactions make up like a large bulk
of the movies at one time yeah but I
found they weren't that interesting
there wasn't much to him yeah well I
mean I thought they were interesting and
like I said there was there was bigger
questions about like what was going on
and like what you know because some of
the stuff she said it was like I was
like why would she lie about that why
would she you know what I mean and you
weren't sure like what their motivations
were so I found that kind of compelling
but like I said even if it was me if I
was editing it I might have turned down
they should the scenes a little they
should have made her like genetically
modified yeah okay well like I said she
might have been but yeah but they should
have made it they should have made a
definitive earlier on in the movie and
then there was something bad about her
yeah you know I mean something you know
like she had tentacles that would come
out of closeted come on she looked like
a girl but she wasn't one really and if
you had sex with her she could kill you
that something like that she had couch
tentacles well she'd get you pregnant
that'd be some fun so interesting
she'd get you pregnant or maybe she'd
hijacked your mind and she'd be like a
queen bee and you get if they did do a
lot with the Viet and that she'd be she
was like a queen bee DNA in her and she
would make you a drone yeah and you had
a server and then you planting all these
eggs and there's these little clones of
yourself like be like clones of yourself
being born see it be like see you need
to hire me funny cuz I come up with some
[ __ ] [ __ ] up you're raising this
brood of clones of you right and they're
all horny bastards they're trying to
have sex with you like some crown burger
come up with that does sound like a
cronut burger
hey David burger if you're listening all
right but yeah so check it out if you
like that kind of thing you might like
that kind of thing Tom didn't like it
yeah but you know I kind of liked it but
I did think good quality movie but I did
think it was a little bit flow but I
liked it oh there's a good quality movie
with good actors in it actually was kind
of I would say it was well executed it
looked cool it just wasn't very fun to
watch and I didn't really like it okay
fair enough we will see you next time
[Music]